[Applause]
going to the galaxy - is the latest film
to prove that while CGI is neat and
sometimes necessary practical effects
are what really make movies magic ever
since Jurassic Park came out in 1993 and
showed that a computer could bring
dinosaurs back to life CGI is taken over
special effects in film but the truth is
some of the most memorable movie scenes
involved practical effects practical
effect or special effect is one that is
produced physically and without the aid
of CGI
this can include rain explosions
animatronics puppets and makeup while it
is certainly not without CGI
going to the galaxy vol 2 is the latest
movie to incorporate practical effects
yes CGI can give us outer space but you
can thank special effects for this wild
car crash and these explosions there's a
storied history of doing things
practically in Hollywood it goes all the
way back to the silent era even if you
haven't seen it you probably know this
iconic shot from safety laughs and which
hero Boyd dangles from a clock over a
busy street thanks now the cameras place
your sense of perspective is manipulated
and you'll never realize that he's
actually just feet above a platform
doing things practically can get
expensive but at one point there was no
other option Buster Keaton silent comedy
the general included a real train and a
real bridge collapse
at the time film's budget was $750,000
that was a lot back in 1926 to this day
one of the most impressive is the attack
on a Turkish train in Lawrence of Arabia
which came out in 1962 the scene was
shot in southern Spain was stood in for
Jordan they only had one chance to get
this right and boy did they open the pod
bay doors hell I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that 2001 a Space
Odyssey came out in 1968 if it were made
today it would probably have been
entirely CGI instead the visually
groundbreaking film was shot on sound
stages in England everything from the
eight men to the space ship still hold
up today the film took home one Oscar
for Best Visual Effects it would be the
only Oscar legendary director Stanley
Kubrick would ever win you're going to
need a bigger boat working practically
isn't always easy
take jaws for instance the making of
Spielberg horror classic was a disaster
as the film ran over budget and past
schedule making things even more
difficult the mechanical shark often
malfunctioned
however this turned out to be a blessing
in disguise
to avoid this problem Spielberg decides
to keep the shark off-screen as often as
possible just giving us the briefest of
glimpses this mystery is exactly what
made the movie so scary and why jaws is
known as the first true summer
blockbuster a CGI shark would be much
easier and more cost efficient but a
sharknado demonstrated not quite as
compelling many of today's directors
haven't forgotten about the pure magic
of physically bringing something to life
in a common move guardians of the galaxy
to use both visual and practical effects
many scenes are real while others got
filled in later on even in the jungle
book in which basically every character
and setting or CGI actor Neel Sethi
still had to fit through a rainstorm
some modern movies really go all out for
the zero-gravity fights being an
inception crystal
spent a good chunk of the movies 160
million dollar budget building some real
sects such as the upside-down hallway
that led to this memorable fight clean
eight of the Furious pushed a bunch of
cars off a six-story garage during a
chase scene Captain America Civil War
flipped the truck over there is no way
the action scenes in Mad Max fury road
would have been so intense had they not
actually filmed them overall CGI is
important and can allow filmmakers to
build new worlds and characters that
would be impossible to find in the real
world
however there's just nothing like some
good old-fashioned practical effects
aged better over time require more
ambitious thinking and simply put look
awesome